let's now evaluate this green surface
integral right over here and to do that
we need to parameterize surface two so
let's say surface two can be represented
by the vector position function i'll
just call it t t for two
so t
t which is a vector it's going to be a
function of x and y those are are going
to be our parameters and it's going to
be equal to and we can do this once
again because we're dealing with our
surface is a function of x and y
so it's going to be equal to x times i
plus y
times j
plus
f 2
of x y
f 2 of x y times k
4
4
x for all the x y's that are a member
that are a member of our domain now that
out of the way we can re-express what k
dot n d s is so let me write this over
here k
k
k
dot
dot n
d s
is equal to and we could put parentheses
here that we're going to take this dot
product that's at least how i like to
think about it this is the exact same
thing as k
as k
dotted with
dotted with the cross product of
the cross product of the partial of t
the partial of t let me make this clear
the partial under the magenta color the
partial of t
with respect to x crossed with the
partial of t with respect to y
times
a little chunk of our area times d a a
little chunk of our area in the x y
domain we've done this multiple times as
we evaluated surface integrals and we
got the intuition for why this works and
so that we're essentially just
evaluating the surface integral and the
one thing we want to make sure is make
sure this has the right orientation
because remember in order for the
divergence theorem to be true the way
we've defined it is all the normal
vectors have to be outward facing so for
this top surface the normal vector has
to be pointing straight up
the normal vector has to be pointing
straight up or not necessarily straight
up at least upwards if this is a curve
it wouldn't be nicely straight up but
needs to be up kind of outward facing
like that on the sides it would be
outward facing like that and down here
it would be outward facing going in the
general downwards direction so let's
just make sure that this is upwards
facing if we go if we're changing with
respect to x we're going in this
direction changing with respect to y
we're going in that direction take the
right hand rule with the cross product
index finger there middle finger there
your left your thumb or your right thumb
i should say will go straight up so it
goes in the right direction so this
would be an upward pointing vector so we
got the right orientation
we got the right orientation for our
surface now let's think about what this
is and it's important to realize
we could calculate all of the components
of this but then we're just going to
take the dot product of that with k so
it's really we care about the k
component only but i'll work it out so
this is equal to
this is equal to k
k times
k
times
a matrix i
j
k
of the partial of t with respect to x
well the partial of t with respect to x
i'll do this in blue is going to be 1 0
1
0 and the partial of f 2
partial of f2 with respect to x and then
the partial of t with respect to y is
just going to be 0 1
0 1 and the partial of f 2
partial of f 2 with respect to y
and then of course we have to multiply
times d a
d
a and this is all going to be equal to
this is all going to be equal to k
unit vector k
dotted with
dotted with and i don't even have to
even work it all out it's going to be
something times the i unit vector minus
something checkerboard pattern
minus something times something else
necessarily times our j unit vector plus
and now we can think about the k unit
vector so the k unit vector is going to
be 1 times 1 minus 0. so it's just going
to be plus
the k unit vector we know it's 1 times
the k unit vector and so when you take
this dot and of course we have our
da out right here but when you take this
dot product you only get are left with
the k components and it's essentially
just 1 times 1 you end up with a scalar
quantity of 1 all of this business just
simplified
all of this business just simplified 2
d a
so now we can rewrite our surface
integral and we're going to rewrite it
in the x y domain now in our parameters
domain so our surface integral right up
here let me so this will be good for
this video and then we'll do the same
thing with this surface here just making
sure that we get the orientation right
so this surface integral
s2
s2 and i'll even rewrite a little bit s2
which is a function r is a function of x
y and z
times k dot n
k
dot n
d s
i just rewrote all of this right up here
is equivalent to the double integral
over our parameters domain which is just
d
of
r of x y z times all of this business
all of this business just simplified to
d a and since i want to write it in
terms of my parameters i can i'll write
it as r
r of x
y and while we're on that surface z is
equal to f 2
so it's x y and f 2
of
x y and then all of this business we
just saw simplified
simplified to d a so you might be saying
hey sal i didn't look like you
simplified it a lot
but at least now put it in terms of a
double integral instead of a surface
integral so at least in my mind that is
a simplification and the next video
we're going to do the exact same thing
with this just making sure that our
vectors are oriented properly and we
could just introduce a negative sign to
make sure that they are and then we'll
think about and then we're going to
think about the triple integrals and try
to simplify those